en une phrase laconique la cour suprême
américaine inflige un énième revers à
donald trump
la demande d'injonction présentés au
juge a dit haut et déférés devant la
cour a été rejeté les neuf juges ont
refusé de se saisir d'un recours formulé
par les républicains pour bloquer la
certification des résultats de la
présidentielle dans l'état clé de
pennsylvanie donald trump avait pourtant
espéré que la plus haute juridiction du
pays interviendrait en sa faveur
la cour suprême qui compte trois
magistrats sur neuf nommés par le
milliardaire n'a pas motivé sa décision
le président républicain refuse toujours
plus d'un mois après l'élection de
concéder sa défaite face au démocrate
joe biden se présentant comme victimes
de fraudes massives il a introduit avec
l'aide de ses alliés des plaintes dans
plusieurs états clefs quasi toutes ont
déjà été rejetées par les tribunaux
l'une d'elles porté par l'élu
républicain de la chambre des
représentants mike kelly contesté la
légalité des votes par correspondance en
pennsylvanie en opposant une fin de non
recevoir
les neuf juges de la cour met un terme à
cette procédure la cour suprême a rejeté
les dernières tentatives pour remettre
en cause les résultats en pennsylvanie
cette élection est terminée nous devons
continuer de stopper ce cirque de
poursuites et aller de l'avant
l'état du texas dirigé par les
républicains introduit mardi un autre
recours devant la plus haute juridiction
du pays pour demander l'invalidation des
résultats dans quatre autre état clé
mais selon les experts il n'a pas plus
de chance d'aboutir